hi I'm Will Ferrell and I'm Zach above
seven áthis
as serious musicians it is our pleasure
to step out from our day jobs for a
moment to present the Oscar for Best
Original Song one of our nominees will
join the ranks of previous winners when
you wish upon a star Moon River the way
we were and it's hard out here for a
pimp
you're the nominees
and the Oscar goes to
Brett Mackenzie for man or Muppets the
Muppet
Bret McKenzie based in New Zealand is a
member of Flight of the Conchords and
his musician behind the original
soundtrack to the Muppets
Wow thank you Academy I grew up in New
Zealand watching the Muppets on TV never
dreamed I get to work with them and I
was genuinely starstruck when I when I
finally met Kermit the Frog but once you
once you get to know him he's just a
normal frog and like many stars here
tonight he's a lot shorter in real life
just a few jokes okay I'd like to thank
everyone who worked with me on the film
especially James Bobin
for doing such a perfect job of bringing
the song to life on screen Micky
petrolia for getting such a sweet sound
Disney for making movies with songs in
them
my wife Hannah our two kids Vito and Leo
for all their love and support my
friends and family at home especially my
parents for never telling me to get a
real job
and finally Jim Henson and his original
team for creating the magical world of
the Muppets it's a true honor to work in
the shadows of such religions thank you
you